gratitude and perspective that's the
focus of tonight's angle now two months
after the corona virus entered the
United States via China let's not forget
where it came from it's taken the lives
of at least 27 Americans and infected
nearly 800 now these numbers will grow
over the next weeks and months and they
probably don't tell an accurate picture
right now because of our relatively
small testing sample we've already
talked about this we all know that
businesses and workers are already
beginning to hurt working parents are
dealing with the disruption of school
closures I'm one of them my kids are out
for the next week at least
it omits to all of the bad news we have
to keep our perspective there is some
good news our economy is the best in the
world
why due to the policies and the
foresight of President Trump he
understands the importance remember this
it's very critical to remember this at
this time of preserving strong nation
states namely our own and this solid
foundation the resilience of our
workforce our ability to learn lessons
quickly in these types of situations
should give us full confidence then
we're gonna weather this just fine in
the end but imagine how much worse this
situation could be right now
if we didn't have a president who acted
fast to stop travel from key high-risk
areas and we not acted quickly that
number would have been substantially
more we're taking this unbelievably
seriously the biggest thing that we did
was stopping the inflow of people early
on and that was weeks ahead of schedule
weeks ahead of what other
and what if what if the Wuhan virus had
hit after Hillary Clinton had won the
presidency if her handling of Benghazi
is any guide it would have been a
nightmare
and certainly her economy would have
already stalled if Santa under her
economic policies wonder if has seen the
economic growth we saw under President
Trump and what about if Sanders R Biden
were president same problem only worse
okay is a human right we need a
medicare-for-all take on the existential
threat of climate change and you know
creating in the process will create over
10 million good-paying jobs not 15 bucks
an hour 45 50 bucks an hour with
benefits okay if you believe that more
government control shut down oil and gas
and as to how they would actually handle
a corona virus outbreak do we really
think they'd move to stop travel and
shut down the southern border if you had
to would you close down the borders no
we have a president who has a propagated
xenophobic anti-immigrant sentiment from
before he was elected what we need to do
is have the scientists take a hard look
at what we need to do I'll translate for
you no he would not bring in more
Chinese that's all we have to handle
this problem and after your tax dollars
are used to develop a vaccine a Sanders
administration would have wanted you to
cover the cost for everyone okay but
also for everyone across the globe when
that vaccine is developed obviously it
should be made free to every person in
this country and in fact every person in
the world why not and never content to
let a good crisis go to waste
the left would use this health emergency
to spend money on stupid programs any
excuse to grow our all
bloated government we had to talk about
unemployment insurance we want paid sick
leave and emergency unemployment
insurance what they do need is paid sick
leave all right with Democrats in charge
we would apparently not be leaving our
houses at all at least not to go to
campaign rallies let's be fair
can't wouldn't beat your opponent can't
win
well order him or her to stop holding
all rallies the Trump pence campaign
will continue to hold rallies given the
fact that all these doctors and medical
professionals are saying avoid large
crowds he's not really doing what
they're telling people older people to
do the fact that he is not willing to
cancel his various rallies suggests that
he is willing to place even his most
ardent supporters at risk yeah that's
what he's doing Jackie by the way both
Sanders and Biden cancelled their own
election night rallies tonight and
supposedly was out of concern for public
health and safety really what was this
done to save lives or save face the
great socialist dream of the Sanders
crowd was over even before tonight let's
face it so I forced yourself to address
this embarrassment in front of the
cameras
this evening and speaking of
embarrassment old Joe he just needs to
stay away from the microphones and
perhaps take a nap beyond the partisan
bickering and fear-mongering now is the
time for America to stand united
preparation not panic is key to coping
with this virus if changes have to
happen to our response they have to be
made and they have to be made quickly we
all know by now that many of the CDC's
early Coronas coronavirus tests were
faulty that was no doubt very
problematic yet President Trump acted
fast he cut through the FDA's red tape
soon millions of tests will be available
even Democrat governors who've said some
really nasty things about Trump are now
lauding his administration's response we
had a very long conversation
and every single thing he said they
followed through I believe the agencies
of the federal government are being very
diligent in helping our state in times
of crisis it helps to have a president
who makes his own decisions
who marshals the right resources and
surrounds himself with the most
competent people to do the job he
doesn't give in to the bureaucracy he
bends it to be more nimble he pushes
obstacles out of the way and solves
problems he has a take-charge hands-on
approach to the coronavirus and every
other problem he faces he'll work with
Democrats on a legislative package to
help working families he'll do for our
emergency response system what he's done
for our economy make it stronger and
better day by day and that's the angle